hello everyone and welcome to the 2018
World Chess Championship match between
Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano Caruana this
is game 11 and if you haven't been
following the championship so far I will
put a link to all the 10 previous games
in the description below so you can
follow it up if you feel like it if not
all of the games so far have been drawn
so 10 draws in a row and I believe this
makes it a record regarding World Chess
Championship matches there have never
been 10 draws in a row in a row Chess
Championship match it's still hard to
say if you ask either of them or I mean
they were asking the press conference
who is now the favorite here as there
are only two more games left before
before the rapid playoffs but Carlsen is
fairly confident as the one would assume
but Khurana says that his chances are
not as low as everyone says they are so
before we check out the actual game we
do have a couple of nice photos or again
compliments of Nicky Riga so let's check
him out here we have a very nice photo
in this game the first move was made by
the 2016 World Chess Championship
challenger it is the man himself Sarah
Kerrigan and he also like Woody
Harrelson decided to play a little joke
he opened the with pawn to b4 for
Carlsen so quite a move from the former
World Chess Championship Challenger as
you can see they are all really having
the time of their life here you can see
he he checks with Carlsen is is
everything okay with the before will he
actually play it I mean a Kawara most
likely knows it's a joke but I mean you
can never be too sure this is a the last
time in the match before the playoffs
that Carson actually has the white
pieces so he might he might even go for
before you never know what's going on
you can see on his face that yeah it's a
joke but it also might not be and here
we have a photo of course and saying
correct in why I do this to me but later
in the press conference I've learned
that Carson was actually informed some
two minutes prior to this that Kerrigan
will pull this joke and here we have
Kirkland was also a guest in the
official stream their habit he's
explaining to you detent and I like why
he made it a little
joke with the before move how he has a
lot of followers on Instagram and also a
lot of very cool stuff how he was the
better challenger in 2016 then Corwin is
in 2018 and so on and so on I actually
totally made up the last two things but
you know I have no idea what they were
talking about so there you have it so
like we said Carson has the white pieces
and he opens with not before the move
Kerrigan so conveniently you know played
but rather efore again Carson wants to
test out kiwanis better of defense and
okay e5 with Knight to f3 Knight to f6
the better of Defense's on the board
Knight captures on d5 d6 and here Carson
doesn't retreat like in the previous
game where he tested Coronas better off
would Knight to b3 but rather he goes to
Knight to f3 this is the classical
variation and now we have Knight
captures on e4 we have Knight to c3
Knight captures B captures and here this
is my favorite line personally with the
white pieces against the petrov as now
well it's a very enjoyable line to play
you can freely develop your bishops I
mean it's a fairly open game but if you
play it like in bliss games or if you
played against some weaker opponents you
will usually encounter this Bishop to g4
move where you can immediately punish it
with h3 after black moves back you will
play Queen d5 attacking the bishop
attack to b7 pawn and here if black
wants to keep everything intact you will
he will have to give up the bishop here
and now you will have won the bishop
repair it will be fairly hard for blacks
to develop if knight c6 then Bishop can
come to b5 if c6 Queen g3 again
hindering blacks development so a very
enjoyable position for white about okay
after D captors on c3
Bishop to e7 by Caruana would have
Bishop to e3 and now Corona castles
Queen to d2 and the Knights to d7 this
entire game has already been played
before but we'll get more into that a
bit later
a queenside castle by Carlsen Knight to
f6 and it's very interesting if you
remember that entire video gate thing
that was going on where the st. was just
lob a leak to that footage where
Caruana had some preparations and some
of the lines were visible so then
everyone was like was it done on purpose
so they would confuse Coulson's team
prepare for lines that karana wasn't
even planning or was just a silly
mistake here it's fairly interesting
this Knight to d7 to f6 the line of the
petrov was actually one of the lines
shown in that video and what makes it
even more interesting after Bishop to d3
what Carson played here Khurana played
c5 and again Khurana caught Carson
a lot of preparation because Carson was
definitely not prepared for this
I see if I move and here he took again
some 10 minutes to muster up or reply so
very interesting here this Knight d7 to
f6 you see it in corona sleek the video
that regards this preparation of the
Petrov line and then of course you just
don't prepare for it which makes sense
Bishop to d3 c5 and here across and
simply goes rook HD 1 also an
interesting line is Knight to g5 simply
you know going for for a very nice too
loud attack and after h6 it makes sense
to play actually h4 and here if black
captures white would eventually end up
winning this game
now you will either either have to give
up the night or you will move the knight
and then to lose the game terribly after
Bishop to h7 King h8 root gauge to the
other group is coming to h1 and the
black is getting checkmated our problem
is after this Knight to g5 black doesn't
have to react in such a foolish manner
or he can simply go d5 you don't play a
nice central move and now the pawns are
very dangerous here he will simply
ignore the night and g5 and after
something like King b1
he will also start attacking on the
Queen side so it would the result in a
very double-edged position cross and
instead goes rook h t1 and here we have
Bishop to b6 attacking da to pawn king
to be won and now comes Queen 2 a1 Queen
to a5 and here black is threatening
checkmate if white makes a silly move
then black while white of course is
getting checkmated here so you have to
play something after Queen a5 it's not
all that impressive to go with something
like a 3
then after c4 attacking the bishop
bishop moves now comes Knight to e4 with
an attack on call since Queen Queen to
c1 and now d5 and the black is getting a
lot of action going on in the center and
also on the Queen side
so here Carson is basically forced into
the next line he plays c4 offers the
Queen trade we have Queen captures and
here comes Bishop characters on d2 and
this is the move that well Caruana was
most likely a super prepared up until
this point most likely he was expecting
for something like Knight captures and
then after Knight to g4 which is after
the bishop gets attacked b3 defending
the c4 pawn and then after Knight
captures you capture with the rook and
yes black does get the Bishop repair but
still a white will play something like
94 to c3 to d5 and after this night
reaches d5 you know long you no longer
have the C pawn or the e pawn to get to
get it away from d5 so at some point you
will have to give up the light square
bishop if you want to get rid of this
night from d5 so yeah it would be
winning a bishop pair but not really
it's okay Bishop captures here instead
of Knight captures we have h6 by Caruana
it's took him some six and a half
minutes for this move and this is the
first time that he actually spent time
in this game also a known move here in
this position as there was already a
game played with these exact same moves
is rook F the e8 it was played in the
game since E current versus meters
mishchenko in 2018 in the st. Louis
winter event and that game ended in a
draw so here Bobby goes h6 and now we
have an entirely new game this game is
not available in any of the databases
and here there again there is a lot of
possibility here here we have Knight to
h4 and the Caruana decides for rook F to
e e8 of course you have to notice that
the g6 square is very weak now the
knight comes to g6 then even if capture
denied the bishop on e6 becomes a target
so here one of the moves that Caruana
could have played is Knight to g4 but
tonight the g4 is pretty much a force to
draw a sequence after Knights the g 6f
capture Sanji's
rook captures on e6 and Knight captures
an f2 going for the rook here
rogue detaii one going after the bishop
on e7 and now Knight chapters on d3 see
capture son d3 and now rush up to f6
rook captures on the six now comes Luke
F the e8 challenging White's rock on e1
rook to d7 going after the b7 pawn but
now simply b6 and after rook captures on
e8 rook captures you will not be well
you're not gonna achieve much by
capturing an a7 because if you capture
here then look to e2 is a very strong
going after the bishop going after the G
to pawn and it will be you know a droid
Schleich ending so what Knight to g4
would actually do here is force that
draw drawn sequence so rook to f28 was
played by Khurana and now comes nice to
g6 from Carlsen and here he does go
Knight to g4 if you go something like
Bishop to d8 simply move the bishop then
this night is coming to f4 with an
attack on the bishop on e6 after remove
the Bishop captures captures and after a
three are controlling the knight on f6
you would have pushed back blacks pieces
somewhat so maybe maybe it would be
better for white but okay after 96 we
have Knight to g4 finally and now comes
Knight captures on e7 rook captures in
the look to e2 defending the f2 pawn
Knight to e5 and here we have again a
pretty much forced the sequence that
goes into a lot of trades Bishop to f4
Knight captures on d3 rook captures on
d3 and now rook to d7 of course you
cannot capture on c4 here would be nice
but your rook is hanging on e7 so here
you'd be just down apiece so after rook
captures on d3
rook to e7 was played protecting the
pawn on d6 as now there's actually
threats of the capturing on c4 rook
captures on d6 rook captures Bishop
captures but now rook to d8 first as the
bishop cannot move due to problems on
the back rank so rook to d2 defending
with Bishop captures on c4 as they
decided to traded this d6 pawn for a c4
pawn king to c1 prepare
to defend it the rock on D - and now b6
we have Bishop to f4
rook captures and D - King captures on D
- and here we have an end game which
opposite colored bishops where there are
three pawns on the Queen side and three
pawns on the King set so it's basically
a perfectly you know identical but not
identical but you know three points on
the King set three pawns on the Queen
side each and each a dark square bishop
or White's King is somewhat more active
but we'll see what happens here an
interesting would be Bishop captures on
a - it would be fitting you know if
Caruana did this the way Fischer did it
against Spassky but here it actually
wouldn't work after but after B 3 and C
4 you would get King 2 C 3 and now after
pawn captures came to be - and now the
bishop is definitely trapped you're
threatening to capture on b3 and there
are no tricks with pawn captures here
because you can seem to capture the
queening square is guarded by the bishop
on f4 so here after King captures on D 2
we have a 6 and a 3 if you go for
something like Bishop to c7 it does seem
like you're threatening to win a pawn
after pawn here Bishop attacks pawn it
doesn't really work because of Bishop
captures an A - now you can actually
capture this pawn as the Bishop from f4
is no longer guarding the queening
Square after b3 you can push c4 but now
the same idea doesn't apply here pawn
captures and c3 a c2 actually does work
now you cannot capture the bishop as
black get the Queen into the game so
after a 6 we have a 3 and now King to
affect Fabi starts bringing his King
into the game rush up to c7 now going
after the b6 pawn and yes c5 pawn will
be lost with tempo but again you can
give up give up one point is it's an
endgame of opposite colored bishops we
have b5 Bishop to d6 check King moves
and now Bishop captures and c5 we have
h5 now as Carlson has a dark square
Bishop Bobby wants to place all of his
pawns on light squares which is exactly
what he will do and calls and will at
some point have to place all of his
bones on dark squares at some point in
the game I might have said that they
both have a dark square Bishop where in
fact they are opposite color Bishop so
you know basically I I misspoke there
King 37 King Tubby for again bringing
the King into the game g6 putting in the
pawns on light squares so they are they
aren't targets in the future
g3 cousin does the same Bishop to e2 and
now comes Bishop to f8 King to c6
we have b3 you have to try at least
something if you immediately put all of
your pawns just on dark squares then you
know it's it's a dead draw immediately
here Carlson at least wants to try
something with c4 we have rush up to d1
now comes King to d3 bishop goes back to
g4 and now c4 we have Bishop to e6 King
to d4 we have pawn captures on c4 pawn
captures on c4 and now Bishop back to g4
we have c5 that c5 point is now very
nicely protected on c5 and also one of
the interesting things is that even if
this King goes all the way to the King
side and the White King somehow tries to
go over to capture the a3 pawn this as
soon as this point is captured then this
comes with check so also I think to
consider Bishop to e6 by Caruana
rush up to h6 now comes Bishop to d5 and
now Bishop to e3 Bishop to e6 and now
King to e5 Bishop to d5 came to f4
Bishop to e6 and now kink the g5 here
across and has a very nice idea but
you'll see you'll see what happens
Bishop to d5 we have g4 by Carlson pawn
captures the King captures and now comes
a bishop to a to an interesting maneuver
would have been if something like came
to d7 is played now comes f4 if Bobby
just decided to repeat King c6 we have H
for Bishop to e4 King g5 Bishop to d3
and now after f5 you would have this
situation where if you actually capture
the pawn then why would have a winning
position because now h5 would be winning
just so we get an idea of how this
entire entire situation can go wrong for
black so now of course you will either
have to ignore the pawn and allow it to
be queen or you will capture it and then
white will cap
this bishop and win the game but of
course Khurana doesn't go for that he
was Bishop to 82 we have King to g5 with
Bishop to b3 King to f6 Bishop play to
h4 now Bishop to b3 we have f4 and
Bishop back to a 2 again interestingly
if you go Bishop to e6 to prevent to
this point from coming to a5 you will
face the same you know idea f5 simply
and now you will either have the capture
with this pawn and now there's no way of
preventing this point from queening or
you will capture with the bishop and
then again h5 wins as you will either
have to let it slide all the way to h8
or you will capture and then I lose the
bishop this point is protected it's an
easily winning game yeah there are no
chances here for black but Fabi of
course sees all that he was Bishop to 88
2 we have f5 by Carson and here a hobby
simply ignores him Bishop to be one
Bishop to F 2 and after Bishop to see to
the players agreed to a draw on more 53
and as you can see even game 11 was
drawn there's nothing really to do here
you can simply just move the bishop back
and forth or even if you have changed
something here
push h5 or or whatnot it's still it's
still a draw nothing to be done here but
yeah after a bishop to c2 they agree to
a draw and there is only one more game
left in the classical time format and
it's very interesting so if you imagine
the match so far has been drawn and now
it's like the World Chess Championship
is to be decided in one game where
Caruana has the white pieces so if you
look at it like that Quran is definitely
a huge favorite now as cousin has to
defend his title with the black pieces
so far I mean he did create most of his
chances with the black pieces and most
of the you know creative games were
where he had the black pieces but also a
very interesting aspect of this world
chess championship match is that Crossan
always gets out prepared by Caruana so
that's this really interesting is it I
mean what's the idea here is it due to
due to laziness due to bad work of his
entire team how does the other guys team
always out prepares you and I mean
you're the world champion you
you definitely should not be out
prepared so so often in a world
championship match so very interesting
and again it's very interesting that
cost can actually decided to go for a
four in this game as Caruana being such
an expert on the petrov not it's it's
hard to imagine that he could have hoped
to achieve some advantage here with the
white pieces but yeah I just think that
at but by this point he already feels
that his best chances are either in game
12 with the black pieces where heater
prepared something insane or he will
just go into tie breaks in faster time
controls and look for his chances there
so I'm also very interested in what do
you think how this match is doing where
is this going and you don't feel free to
share your comments in the description
below I would also like to thank Carsten
quartz Lars Allspark
Glenn Brecht Turk like consulting and
James Polk for a contribution to my
channel thanks a lot I really appreciate
it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content maybe even
check up on some of your suggestions as
tomorrow is the rest day before the
final game thank you all and I will see
you soon